DROP IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION?
>> Bret: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
MORE ON THIS WITH THE PANEL.
FIRST, SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ALL OF THIS.
>> WELL, IT WAS PRETTY STRIKING
AND SUDDEN.
IT'S TRUE OF COURSE HE WAS
EXPECTED TO RETIRE WITHIN A
MATTER OF MONTHS BUT NOT
NECESSARILY TODAY.
OF COURSE, THE SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS RAISES QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE A STAFF MEMO,
COMPENDIUM THAT THE REPUBLICAN
STAFF ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE PUT TOGETHER.
OUT.
NOW, THAT MAY BE A COINCIDENCE
BUT I THINK WE ARE JUSTIFIED IN
SUSPECTING THERE WAS SOMETHING
IN THE DOCUMENT.
ALARMED CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND HE
GAVE THE WORD TO McCABE THAT
YOU BETTER GET OUT OF HERE
BEFORE IT HITS.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE REPORTING ON
WHETHER THE     THE DOCUMENT ISR
WHETHER THE     THE DOCUMENT ISL
WHETHER THE     THE DOCUMENT ISA
WHETHER THE     THE DOCUMENT ISE
WHETHER THE     THE DOCUMENT ISD
PUBLICLY.
>> Bret: HERE IS WHAT
DEMOCRATS SAY PRETTY MUCH IN
UNISON.
THAT'S THAT ALL OF THIS IS
INTO RUSSIAN COLLUSION, WHEREVER
MUELLER GOES.
AND THEY SAY IT'S STRIKING THAT
AN ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING SUCH
STRIKES AND SWIPES AT THE FBI
THAT HAD BEEN LARGELY RESPECTED
FOR DECADES.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS SAY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> THEY CERTAINLY DO.
IF IT TURNS OUT THERE'S NOTHING
WHATEVER TO THESE SUGGESTIONS
THERE'S BEEN IMPROPER CONDUCT BY
THE FBI AND PERHAPS OFFICIALS AT
MAIN JUSTICE DURING THE COURSE
OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS, THE ONE
INTO HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN
ON THE ONE INTO DONALD TRUMP AND
THE FBI TOOK.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT AND THERE HAS
BEEN ENOUGH SMOKE IN THESE
HIGHLY PARTISAN, ANTI-TRUMP TEXT
MESSAGES WE'VE SEEN FROM TOP
JUSTICE AND FBI INVESTIGATORS TO
MAKE US WONDER.
WHAT'S MORE, THERE'S NO REASON
TO INVESTIGATIONS CAN'T GO
FORWARD SIMULTANEOUSLY.
THERE'S NO REASON TO THINK ANY
OF THIS IS GOING TO DERAIL THE
SO MY FEELING ABOUT THIS IS FOR
PEOPLE WHO SAY IT'S A
DISTRACTION AND THAT IT'S
DAMAGING, SUGGESTS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CANNOT CONTEMPLATE TO
INVESTIGATIONS AT ONCE.
THAT'S NONSENSE.
>> Bret: FOR SOMEONE LIKE TREY
GOWDY TO SAY HE'S CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT HE HAS SEEN RAISES A
LOT OF EYEBROWS.
>>
TREY GOWDY HAS BEEN PRETTY
RESPONSIBLE ON THIS.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN, NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT.
HE HAS PARTISAN OBJECTIVES
PERHAPS BUT LOOK, IT WAS TREY
GOWDY WHO APPARENTLY HE TALKED
DEVIN NUNES INTO HAVING THE FBI
DIRECTOR COME UP TO EXAMINE THE
MEMO AHEAD OF TIME.
THEY ARE BEING PRETTY CAREFUL.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
FORMAL PROCESS FOR
DECLASSIFICATION OF MATERIAL
WHICH I THINK IS RESPONSIBLE.
THERE IS SOME REASON TO TAKE